if you walked away from Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom with a bit of whiplash
don't be alarmed
the sequel easily feels like three
different movies crammed into one and
each act presents his own unique horrors
before the Big Finish brings everything
together and swiftly smashes it all to
bits taking place three years after the
events of Jurassic world it takes some
suspension of disbelief to get our old
friends Owen and Claire back to Isla
Nublar and if as it goes just about as
smoothly as one might expect that's just
a start of their troubles too as they
face even bigger monsters on the
mainland let's take a look at what
exactly happens there at the tail end of
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom and tied
together all of the film's plot threads
a bedside betrayal the introduction of
deep pocketed Dino philanthropist
Benjamin Lockwood explains how Hammond
could afford the original outrageously
expensive Jurassic Park he's also a
friendly face for the new Isla Nublar
expedition one that can convince people
to join in especially those who were
involved with the previous massacre
Lockwood plays on Claire's desire to
save these dinosaurs from certain
extinction by the islands erupting
volcano and she in turn plays on Owens
personal connection to the Raptor Blair
Lockwood may have been sincere about
saving the dinosaurs but his smarmy
assistant Eli Mills is much too greedy
to simply rehouse his animals on some
tranquil island instead he's ready to
round up whatever creatures he can to
auction them off to the highest bidder
at the same time he's also working with
margin ethicist dr. Wu to create an even
more lethal and valuable weapon of war
called the interrupter this thing is a
hybrid of the indominus rex and the
velociraptor and even more menacing than
its parent species once Mills true
intentions are discovered by Lockwood he
decides to smother his longtime
benefactor to death and go about the
business of turning his late boss's
passion project into a personal fortune
anyway what a guy a particular taste
Mills has no trouble rounding up buyers
for his new menagerie of monsters Baloo
was a VIP target Claire and Owen were
recruited to save but it wasn't a
charity mission at all Owens behavior
research with blue is important because
he endo Raptor was created won't work as
is he wants to make another one that
grows up with blue so that it can pick
up a trainer traits of empathy and
emotional intelligence
the prototype thus displayed and them
wisely auctioned off by Mills is a
merciless
killing machine that won't be any good
to a squadron of soldiers running with
it
Owen and Claire could easily walk away
from the fray at Lockwood's estate once
they get the Pachycephalosaurus to break
them out but instead Owen decides to
hang around long enough to ensure Wu's
gene-spliced monstrosity won't ever
leave the manor alive that's when all
hell breaks loose at the Lockwood
auction twisted family tree what Maisie
spends a whole life being cared for by
the ailing secretive man she knows as
her grandpa but he refuses to even show
her a photo of the mother she supposedly
lost a lander in his care after he's
executed by Mills she discovers that
she's a clone of his late daughter and
not actually his granddaughter in other
words it's not just dinosaur DNA that's
creating new life in the story
human beings are also right for the
cloning process now blues on the move as
Mills auction starts to fall apart most
of the dinosaurs are still locked up in
the lower containment area that'll be
all well and good for everyone on site
except that the frakerz eventually
reaches the lower levels when wu demands
are zero and franklin steal bloo's blood
so we can save it for the next horror
hybrid he decides to create the two
refuse and let Palouse loose on the lab
guards but saves them and the raptor
eventually rescues Owen Claire and
Maisie above from the interrupter but
her escape causes a fire blast and a
toxic chemical leak that threatens to
kill all of the rescued dinos in cages
although she spent years trying to save
these exact creatures claire chooses not
to let them out because it's too
dangerous to have them wandering around
civilized society but in a twist maze he
steps up to let them loose anyway she
now knows just how much she has in
common with these engineered creatures
outside Owen asked blue to stick with
him but she decides to check out what
the rest of the world has to offer
instead no more hybrids in the madness
Mills only concern seems to be to
preserve the indominus rex bone they
fished out from the Mosasaurus tank
because of how valuable it will be to
military geneticists however his luck
ultimately runs out and the t-rex
eventually stomps the sample to pieces
which means the indominus rex is gone
but perhaps not forever
the hybrid story could indeed continue
as the Indo Raptor skeleton is down
below Isla Nublar for now though
everyone who was crazy enough to do that
initial dive is dead so we'll have to
wait and see if Jurassic world 3 would
even bother to bring back the hybrid
concept
when they've got so much else to work
with welcome to Jurassic world Ian
Malcolm warned everyone not to save the
dinosaurs from the volcano at Isla
Nublar this is the same guy who once
scolded the Jurassic Park team by saying
your scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they just
everything as I showed and in the end he
ends up explaining to the nation that
humans now have to find a way to adapt
to and coexist with these creatures
lest they be wiped out by them for good
measure we see that scientists have
collected plenty of vials of DNA to
ensure the survival of the species so
it's not just up to the group from
Maisy's are to repopulate their kind
it's legitimately Jurassic world now
humans are now on the defensive and
dinosaurs are ready to inherit the earth
once more as we see in the post-credits
scene which depicts Pteranodons circling
the eiffel tower replicas in las vegas
remember the giant Mosasaurus it's now
on the loose preying on anything it can
find throughout the ocean even worse the
prehistoric beings seemed open to
inviting the rest of modern nature to
rejoin the Wild Kingdom as the t-rex
breaks down and lion's cage and
exchanges a few friendly roars with the
erstwhile king of the jungle if and when
Jurassic world 3 happens it sounds like
it's going to live up to its namesake
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]